when I first started writings it was
like a side thing but then I made this
shift after deep work came out and
suddenly it became I'm a technologist
what you're about to hear is an
interview between me and Cal Newport who
is a computer science professor and also
the author of a bunch of books including
deep work which has become ridiculously
popular in the productivity Niche and
also this fantastic book so good they
can't ignore you which I made a video
about recently that's done very well now
Cal is one of those interesting people
because he straddles the world of like a
traditional Academia as a computer
science professor at Georgetown
University and he also straddles the
world of like online creatory type
people he's been blogging on the
internet since way before it was cool
and so in the conversation we talk about
Cal's career and what it's like to
balance these worlds of like the old
world Prestige of Academia and the new
world Vibes of content creation I think
when people ask me what do you do if I
actually answered I'm a writer I think
it's actually probably higher prestige
in that situation than if I say I'm a
professor like people respect professors
but they often change it the teachings
like oh you teach yeah I was thinking
about teaching it drives academic
professors crazy because it's this like
blood sport intellectual competition
petition to publish incredibly hard
stuff and really competitive venues we
talk about how to reverse engineer a
career based on the lifestyle you want
and we talk about the concept of slow
productivity a lot of my work become a
computer scientist it's productivity but
productivity seen through the lens of
what's happening to our ability to
produce things it's a broad topic and
where I come at it is this technosocial
cultural convergence of trying to figure
out how to take control of what you're
doing in a world in which there's all
these other forces that are trying to
prevent you from exactly having that
control
at the moment according to the YouTube
analytics 81 of you who are watching
this on YouTube have not yet hit the
Subscribe button and so if you're for
example in the now 81 of people who are
watching this on YouTube but who are not
subscribed to the channel I would love
it if you could do so and would be
awesome to get that number down to 50
and it would be cool to get like 50 50
sub non-sub ratio just just for fun
right so Cal thank you so much for
coming on the podcast um this feels
particularly surreal for me because I've
been following your stuff for just I
can't remember I I feel like I was
reading your blog way back in like 2010
or 2011 when you were uh posting about
um how to figure out what to do with
your career and some of the slow
productivity stuff and stuff around like
treating your studies as if they're a
bit more of an adventure
um and that was when I would have been
in high school just before going to
University so it had an enormous impact
on on my life so firstly thank you so
much for for that
yeah well that and that goes way back
there's like three phases of that blog
newsletter the early phase was all
student stuff this was after I first
post my first two books on on student uh
advice and you joined that period
2011-2010 there was this big for me
fraught transition where I said I have
to move on from just doing student
advice and career advice was the thing
and I did a strict 50 50 alternation for
a while and then it evolved from there
into what it is today but that's great
so you're an old timer you're an old
timer on my blogging newsletter yeah
it's great absolutely yeah and I think
kind of my Online Career had a similar
thing where when I started making
YouTube videos in 2017 I was in my sort
of final year of med school and so I
knew that like oh hang on I need to
break out of this student Market pretty
soon and started airing towards like
Tech and then somehow stumbled into the
general genre of productivity and now
I'm this productivity YouTuber
um which feels like a strange place to
be because it's never where I set out to
be but I guess you're like particularly
famous in the productivity world as well
for in particular for deep work
um I wonder like how how do you approach
the word productivity these days
yeah well first of all let me say
there's there's a interesting congruence
between us right because think about we
both were trained you're a doctor right
I mean you were on this very traditional
path that's highly trained and I'm sure
you had very similar sideways glances
and Whisper conversations I was like
what's he doing what's going on on
YouTube and you know I'm a professor so
a very similar sort of thing being
trained and trained to do something very
specific but also was writing and
thinking about all these other issues
that orbited my job and and other types
of issues and so yeah productivity I am
associated with that a lot and and
to some extent I think that's true I I
think a lot about producing good work
producing meaningful work but on the
other hand I don't really come at it
exclusively from the angle of just how
do you maximize what gets done a lot of
my work because I'm a computer scientist
is entangled in techno criticism so it's
it's productivity but productivity seen
through the lens of what's happening to
our ability to produce things because of
email because of social media because of
smartphones because of Zoom invites that
are flying back and forth faster than we
can handle it so it's it's a broad topic
and where I come at it is this
technosocial cultural convergence of
trying to figure out how to
take control of what you're doing in a
world in which there's all these other
forces that are trying to prevent you
from exactly having that control
yeah yeah no that's that's a that's an
interesting lens lens to approach it
with I guess kind of basically all of
deep work was essentially about that and
then obviously a word without email was
specifically and explicitly about that
um I I have to get a bit of a bit of an
understand understanding like what does
a what is a normal week in your life
look like these days and the reason I
ask is because often when I think of
like what do I want my life to look like
in the future and think about vague
long-term plan stuff I often think of
you as being like yeah I think I think
I'd quite like to have a career kind of
like Cal Newport does where it's like
you're a professor of computer science
you're teaching people it seems but on
the side you do you do the blog you do
the books you do the podcast recently
you go on other people's podcasts you
seem to be straddling the the life of
like a traditional academic along with
the sort of being an internet influencer
in like a a weird kind of way so I'd
love to know what that looks like for
you these days
well it's very seasonal which I think is
actually important because that's a
model I think should be more broadly
adopted but only some professions have
it so my typical week right now we're
recording this in the summer as a
professor is going to look a lot
different than let's say next spring
when I'm when I'm teaching uh two
classes but I'll just talk about both
like right now it's the summer time
I'm on my own dime so so the way
professorships work at research
academies is you you are paid for 10
months some places it's nine but but at
Georgetown University where I almost 10
months and then you have two months of
Summer now what a lot of professors do
is uh in your research grants part of
the funding you ask for is summer salary
and that's actually where your salary
comes in July and August I don't do that
because I have income as a writer so I
literally in July and August am not on
georgetown's dime so there's essentially
no work happening other than obviously
my my doctoral students I'm still talk
to work with my students but I I do very
little research and I do nothing on
campus I don't do meetings so a typical
day in the summer like today uh get up
breakfast for the kids I write I go to
my study I have a custom built Library
table that I had built from a company in
Maine that produces Library tables for
universities that's like a big part of
what their work is so it's not a desk
it's actually the dimensions of a live
Library table which is which is
different and I and I sit there and I
write today I wrote until 11AM so it was
like eight eight thirty a.m to about 11
A.M tonight I came to prepare this
midday I do things like this uh I'm
doing an interview with you I owe some
stuff to uh web designer a little bit of
business some email and then I'll shut
that down by four
and work is done so my summer schedule
uh is my ideal schedule and the other
layer I put on top of that by the way is
I try when possible to have two days a
week usually Mondays and one other days
where I schedule nothing
so it's writing in the morning and then
those afternoons is for walking and
thinking so really priming the pump on
the the ideas I'm working out in my
riding the ideas I'm trying to work out
in my more academic thinking that summer
schedule I love it uh if we jump forward
in the fall I'm on teaching leaves it'll
be somewhere in between sort of like
that but more meetings in the afternoons
and going to campus once a week go to
the spring and then it becomes much more
bifurcated uh I teach two days a week
those days it's like for you would have
been the days you're on call I'm on
campus all day I tend to load meetings
with students administrative work Zoom
with administrators all into those days
and they're just let's just get after it
and be exhausted and then let the other
three days be more open like the
schedule so it's very seasonal it really
depends on the seasons you get some
intellectual challenge in the summer but
relaxation for administration and in
other parts of the years maybe it's more
administrative but uh less of the
intellectual challenges so it's a it's a
mix
that sounds pretty pretty fun are you do
you like this kind of variety that you
have
I you know I think it's I think it's
pretty good yeah I mean honestly the
main issue professors have is
Administrative work service wound
obligations that go beyond just doing
the academic work so that's the
you know it's here's what people who
know me know when I'm in the middle of
the busiest parts of the Year from an
academic perspective so for me last
spring I was co-chairing a
university-wide three position search
which was a very time consuming
administrative thing
I'm walking around man I should just
write full time what am I doing here
like I just just go have a cabin and
write this is crazy what a waste of my
time but you talk to me now in the
summer when I have no responsibilities
for the University I'm man I love
Academia there's all these cool people I
work with you know all these ideas I'm
constantly being challenged so I I'm a
little bit Jekyll and Hyde in how I feel
about that it really depends on my
workload
interesting so um I was working with
this um executive coach a couple of
years ago um this was when I just taken
a break from medicine and I hadn't
decided am I going to leave completely
or am I going to do it as like a
part-time gig because I kind of liked
the idea and again I was thinking of
like what is your what does your life
look like I like the idea of maybe uh
practicing medicine like two days a week
maybe one day a week something like that
and then I could spend the rest of the
time doing the thing that I think I'm
actually passionate about which is
writing and reading and learning and
teaching and making videos on the
internet and stuff
um and I was thinking about the idea of
hey you know it would be cool to be like
a teacher at a university maybe I could
teach at a medical school or something
like that and my coach challenged me on
that he was like why why do you need to
be affiliated with an academic
institution could you not just do the
teaching if you if you you know you say
you enjoy teaching in real life why not
just run your own lectures and just do
it without being attached to University
and I was like oh that that's a good
it's a good suggestion it seems like you
get all the benefits of the contact with
students and teaching and stuff without
any of the nightmare admin associated
with being a act actually being involved
with the university
um what's your what's your take on that
like why not just go in your cabin in
the woods and then run seminars on the
weekend which loads of people would
attend probably because you're famous
and good at teaching
um to avoid having all those obligations
well it you know it's a complicated
question I've been surveying a lot of
people I know in various different
relationships to me in various different
professional situations to get their
take on this question and it's it's very
split right so so for example I had a
conversation a couple years back with
Jim Collins who wrote good to Great sort
of famous business writer he was a
business professor at Stanford in his
late 30s so kind of around the same age
I was quit just to write books full-time
and Jim's argument was uh you get just
as much credit
for having done the thing that you get
for still doing a thing in other words
he says I get the credit for having been
a Stanford Business School Professor
like okay that's the credentialing
whatever that gives you is the same as
he was a Stanford Business School
professor
uh and now is no longer because hey it's
if if you were if you were an Olympic
Athlete we trust you know about Fitness
and Nutrition even if you're no longer
uh on on the team other people however
when I ask him this exact same question
we'll say no no no like the if you're
not a professor it's not it's just if
you're not actively a professor it's not
the same you don't have the same
Authority you'll lose your uh Advantage
within the space who are writing uh so
that you know that comes up as well so I
have both of these things both of these
things going on I had one person tell me
and I don't think this is a good cake I
had one person tell me uh no one will
buy your productivity discussions if
they don't see that that you have this
really demanding life
uh being a professor doing these other
things and managing the juggle to which
I was thinking all of my writing on this
for the last multiple years has all have
been about not doing that about
simplifying and slowing down like don't
you think it's actually worse uh I'm
writing a book right now called slow
productivity don't you think it's
actually worse if I have more going on
in my life in some sense it seems like
uh you're not embracing your own ideas
so it I don't I'm curious how you made
that final decision like for for you
how did you deal with here's one of my
questions so so part of like internet
influence right now but even just book
writing forget internet like like I do
it all feels uh a little bit ephemeral
like the technology could change in two
years and it could go away you have two
books that don't hit and the publisher
is not interested like that to me that's
this interesting fear the the stability
uh how did you deal with that thinking
about
I gotta trust that this is a thing
that's also going to be a thing 15 years
from now
yeah honestly this is this is the thing
that keeps me up at night still to this
day and those sort of three different
perspectives that you shared were
basically spot on exactly the three
perspective I I had in my mind where I
was like you know some people were
saying oh once you've been a doctor the
fact that you now practice clinically
one or two days like no one actually
cares beyond that point once you've got
the doctor on the title on the other
hand people are saying no the fact that
you're doing the thing and you're
actually doing the thing is like a
really really important part of it
um and then other people and I I think
this was the story that I was telling
myself a lot was that when I was a
working full-time and making YouTube
videos on the side and running a
business on the side my schedule was
sufficiently demanding to Warrant my
productivity advice and it made my
productivity advice seem more legit
because I was doing the thing but now if
I'm becoming a a YouTuber and a writer
writing about productivity but like the
examples I'm using are from my life as a
person who writes about productivity now
we're in this weird like circular uh
thing where what's what's going to
happen there
um I I haven't haven't yet figured this
out um yeah I'd have to get your take on
it but the way I'm I'm thinking of it is
kind of like
and I don't know if this is legit but I
ask myself you know if I
if I had 100 million in the bank how
would I choose to spend my time if like
we completely removed money from the
equation how would I choose to spend my
time
um and I think the answer to that is
actually broadly the the routine you've
just described of like hey I'd wanna
have breakfast with the family right in
the morning for a few hours until like
midday kind of like the Ryan holiday
lifestyle and then in the afternoon I've
got I can do a podcast I can do video I
can like hang out have lunch with some
friends or just like roam around in
nature
and I think
does any of that does my ideal week in
this world where I don't care about
money does any of it involve actually
practicing medicine I think well maybe
some of it involves teaching medical
students because that's fun or teaching
people but I don't think any of it
involves practicing medicine and then I
was thinking well if if that's the case
then does the fact that I'm entertaining
the decision to continue practicing
clinical medicine is it really only for
the credential and only for the fact
that I can then Flex it on my YouTube
channel in my books and be like oh this
guy's a doctor
um
I felt like that was probably not the
right reason to do it but yeah what's
what's well what's your take on this the
interesting thing is when I'm looking at
your case even though it's very similar
to mine I can have so much more
confidence because it's not me
so I'm like that makes complete I like
that that makes complete sense I mean
people don't realize I think people
don't realize the the overhead of these
really highly skilled credential uh
positions there's there's a lot of
overhead time overhead emotional
psychological overhead uh there's a lot
of frustrations in it I mean they're
they're complicated jobs I'm sure
working for uh National Health Service
has the same weird bureaucratic
complications it's working for for a
large a large University
um so I think that see see for you I
think it makes complete sense because
it's not like
your clinical practice is closely
related in any way to what you're doing
otherwise whereas I have this
complication of I've been shifting my
work more towards basically just an
academic take on similar stuff I work on
working on Tech and culture
techno-social anthropology so there's
this argument to be made that there's
these great thinkers about the impact of
various things on cultures these great
social critics who were in an in
Academia where they were surrounded by
and being challenged by all these
complicated theoretical Frameworks so
this is what I think your decision is
maybe cleaner is that there is
such a difference between day-to-day
clinical practice and the writing and
videos that you produce whereas there's
a play for me where they could be more
integrated so which is just a
complication I think it would almost be
easier if I was a biochemist
and you're like look this is I just and
by the way this is the way that people
and it's a shift that happened and not
to get to Insider baseball but but for
when I first started writing it was that
strict separation I was a grad student
well I started as an undergrad writing
and then as a grad student was writing
student advice books I was studying
computer science it was like a side
thing like oh you write these advice
books it's how I help pay the bills as a
you know on a doctoral student stipend
so they really were unrelated but then I
made this shift after deep work came out
so deep work came out I'm uh you know
Professor I got tenure around that time
I'm like well you know that's really a
book about technology it's about how
technology changed the workplace and why
we have to be worried about those
changes and then then the next two books
I wrote were also about the impacts of
Technology on either our personal or
professional lives and suddenly it
became
I'm a technologist
who also writes about the impact of
technology on various aspects of our
lives and once and then suddenly there
was a congruence which was very useful I
think once my writing fit into my
academic career it really opened up
let's say the sort of mainstream or
Elite press I could get I was sort of
accepted by the the the the New York
Times of the world the New Yorkers of
the world
um the the finance over on your side the
financial times the times of London uh
the guardian these have all been sort of
big supporters of my work so it it they
mesh together and so now I'm a little
bit intertwined uh in a way that I
wasn't before
yeah that's so interesting so like
I I feel like hmm
yeah I appreciate that that's probably
very complicated because from where I'm
sitting it feels like hey once you've
been a professor at Georgetown it's like
you've you've been a computer science
Professor uh and therefore you all
I would I would agree with your friend
who said that oh with Jim Collins that's
surprisingly uh he said that that
credential is
uh the the the currentness of that
credential is not particularly
particularly relevant but I guess this
is the thing that I've often worried
about as well it's like now that I've
left medicine will I actually
have any chance at like mainstream
mainstream Elite uh institution like
legitimacy New York Times guardian and
stuff will they actually care about some
kid who used to be a doctor and now is a
sort of self-help book author for a
living or a self-help influencer for a
living compared to if I was still doing
the thing it's it's that like credential
credentialism and then part of me is
like why why do I care part of me is
like I know I shouldn't care about
trying to hit the New York Times list I
know I shouldn't care about trying to do
this kind of stuff but another part of
me is like yeah but I kind of do and I
guess you're in that position it's like
how do you dissociate things that you
personally care about from the uh uh
accolades and recognition you get from
early institutions well I mean first
your concern is absolutely right like I
have seen this again and again there's
there's um the credentialing required to
be covered by the sort of elite
mainstream Publications it's a very real
thing I mean think about we we mentioned
Brian earlier right Ryan holiday very
influential author very successful
writer uh can't get the time of day
from mainstream Publications the New
York Times did a profile of him a few
years ago but it was snarky it was like
yeah look at this guy trying to
repackage uh you know I I was a few
years ago Mark Manson you know Mark
match the subtle art uh was out here
giving a talk near where I live so we
were kind of killing some time here and
and he was telling a similar Tale one of
the best-selling non-fiction writers of
his generation I mean the number of
copies of books that guy sold very few
non-fiction writers have come near that
I think it's it's up to 20 million
copies now it's hard to underscore just
how successful his books are he can't
get the time of day
he can't get covered no no one's writing
about these books and and I definitely
noticed when I leaned into
my academic credentials when presenting
myself in the publicity of my book it
made a big difference I mean I'm on into
States I do I'm on NPR all the time
you know I do a lot of stuff I used to
do a lot of my last for digital
minimalism the book I wrote In The New
York Times all the time right so that
that is
the concern there is true but I think
your follow-up question is also true how
much do you care about that
you know because it has very little to
do with with the with Book Sales
especially for you you have a huge
audience that you that that knows you
and that you're speaking to and you have
channels for reaching this audience
they're gonna be way more effective
you're only dependent on being covered
in the financial times if you're a CEO
writing a business book that no one will
no one can know about it unless they
actually read about it in a paper so
that's the question of how much do you
how much do you uh how much you care
about that and I think that's that's
probably the the critical question you
could make a play you could have made a
play of Leaning into your doctor like uh
you know nah NHS Doc is uh you know
rethinking the system of how we how we
manage our time and is like speaking out
against the the the uh the the grind of
the sort of knowledge work machinery and
and you could have pulled these things
together and written guardian op-eds and
made yourself into like a fixture like I
am a fixture of sort of like the
standard uh you know be on BBC five all
the time Etc but I don't think you'd
have a bigger audience you know it'd be
it'd be its own type of thing and it's a
little precarious because then you'd be
thinking what if I have the wrong cake
on something you know and because like
you're much more susceptible to that
like uh being in favor and not in favor
so we're speaking the same language and
I think the problem you pointed out is
like a real problem like it does matter
like it is
what gets you covered is narrow but I
think that question of do you care
that's it that's the whole ball game
all right we're just going to take a
quick break from the podcast to
introduce our sponsor which is huel now
this is very exciting because I've
actually been a pain customer of huel
since 2017. I started eating Hill in my
fifth year of medical school and I've
been using heal regularly ever since
because you know I like to be productive
I you know my calendar is full with a
lot of things and often I don't have the
time or don't make the time to have a
particularly healthy breakfast or a
particularly healthy lunch and heal is
fantastic for those occasions because
it's 400 calories they've got tons and
tons of different flavors my favorite
flavor is salted caramel because for
that you get 400 calories you also get
40 grams of protein super hard to get
enough protein in my diet these days
especially with trying to get hinge
working out he'll just make sure that I
get at least those 40 grams in the 400
calories and it's got 26 different
vitamins and minerals which really helps
with the whole healthy balanced diet
thing as well now I don't use heal with
every meal I wouldn't recommend using it
with every meal but in those occasions
where you find yourself reaching for a
very unhealthy snack we're about to
order a really unhealthy takeaway it's
just absolutely fantastic being able to
have the option now I use the heel black
edition in the mornings it's very nice I
put two scoops of powder into my little
blender type I add water sometimes a bit
of milk and that gives me what I need
but also for lunch I like using the huel
hot and savory product they've got which
basically you add boiling water to this
container of stuff and you can make
yourself like a they've got a really
good cheese pasta type one which is
which is my favorite thing and again
also all of these are nutritionally
complete meals they're all vegan they
all have all these nutrients and
vitamins and minerals and stuff and
they're often reasonably high protein as
well and it's also ridiculously cost
effective like one of these meals is one
pound 68 for a 400 calorie meal which is
like a tenth of the price of what I
would be ordering from deliveroo instead
and so really huel is a perfect
companion for a busy life where you want
to get a lot of things done and you
don't if you don't necessarily have a
lot of time to cook a healthy meal and
deal with all the prep and all the
shopping and all the cleanup then heal
is a great addition to your life rather
than a replacement for all of the meals
in your life anyway if that sounds
appeal Street and you want to try out
heal then if you head over to heel.com
forward slash deep dive that URL is a
special URL which will give you a free
t-shirt and a free Shaker thing with
your first order and so yeah head over
to heel.com forward slash deep dive and
thank you so much Hill for sponsoring
this episode
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by trading 212. now people ask me
all the time for advice about investing
because I've made a bunch of videos
about it on the YouTube channel and my
advice for most people is generally
invest in Broad stock market index funds
which is exactly what you can do
completely for free with trading 212.
it's a great app that lets you trade
stocks and funds and ETFs and foreign
exchange if you really want to and one
of the great things about the app is
that if you're new to the world of
investing you can actually invest with
fake money you don't have to put real
money in they've got a practice mode
where you invest fake money and then it
actually tracks what the market is doing
in real time so you can see had I
invested 100 pounds into this thing what
would my return have been X weeks or X
months further down the line once you've
got some comfort with that then it's
super easy to deposit money into your
trading tool into account you can use
Apple pay like I do initially or you can
use a direct bank transfer and then once
the money is in your trading 212 account
then you can invest it in basically
whatever you want the other really cool
feature about trading 212 is their pies
feature so what you can do is you can
follow people who've created investing
pies for example someone might have a
pie where I don't know 30 of its apple
and 20 is Tesla and 10 is the S P 500
and you can follow people on the app and
see what pies they've created and you
can see the performance of those pies
and then you can just copy and paste a
particular pie into your own account and
so that means like let's say you've got
100 pounds to invest and you've put 50
of it into the S P 500 but you want to
be a little bit more experimental with
the other 50 pounds you can invest it
into a pie where someone else is
generally a pro or someone in their
bedroom who just loves the markets has
already done all the homework for you
the app also lets you Auto invest which
is a great thing because then you can
automatically invest a percentage of
your paycheck into the thing every month
and so if you haven't yet started when
investing and you want to give it a go
then you can download the app on the App
Store and if you use the coupon code Ali
Ali at the checkout that will give you a
totally free share worth up to 100
pounds it's available on iPhone and
Android and you can check it out by
typing in trading two one two into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode and I guess part of you know if
we if we zoom into this question of do
you care I guess we've talked about well
does it actually translate to a tangible
bet like a tangible benefit like book
sales or sales of a course or sales of a
thing
but then there there's another like
social status benefit of that
um where you know I still have this
conversation with my mum sometimes where
you know she's a doctor as well and you
know that generation is very much about
um you know her whole thing was like why
why would you leave medicine it's like
such a prestigious profession and like
you respect it in society
um
and I I fully appreciate from her
perspective the decision to leave
medicine to become a YouTuber is just
really freaking weird
um and and so there's still this part of
me that's like sort of
wanting to try and hold on to the the
glory badge of honor of having been at
Cambridge University student and sort of
like oh but that was like four years ago
and I need a new Badge of prestige and
the New York Times list seems like one
of those or becoming a Harvard MBA
student seems like one of those and it's
like I I find myself pulled in this in
this direction where it's like
I could totally make a play for that and
I actually started an application to uh
Stanford and Harvard Business course
like about a year ago uh until loads of
people talked me out of it they were
like look what are you doing like this
really looks like you're chasing a
credential for like literally no reason
but I guess it's so hard to get out that
sort of status seeking mindset
um yeah what does that Vibe with you at
all oh it's so hard yeah I mean that is
really hard like the status stuff
yeah it's interesting because people
talk about it not mattering or people
say like ah look like you're
accomplished man your credential status
or have you done this like yo you're
excited for a moment but then you're
just back and frustrated with uh your
toast burning the next morning it
doesn't really matter just what but but
what what's true about it is like no
there is like a background
a background hum of satisfaction or of
like a little bit of a trickle of Pride
like you know I graduate from Cambridge
like I'm and I kind of have that and
kind of feel good or like I'm a you know
I'm a doctor like it is a real thing I
mean I think we we try to underplay it
but I I think we should face it because
I I find it really hard now the
interesting thing is
if you can say you're a writer I have
the sense that that like in these days
is uh
sort of in a Bohemian way really high
status as well like actually because
I've been thinking about this recently
uh I think when people ask me what do
you do
if I actually answered I'm a writer
I think it's actually probably higher
prestige in that situation than if I say
I'm a professor like people respect
professors but they often change it to
teaching like oh you teach yeah I was
thinking about teaching and it drives it
drives you know academic professors
crazy because it's this like blood sport
intellectual competition to publish
incredibly hard stuff and really
competitive venues oh and you do teach
some courses so when people say oh you
teach I was thinking about teaching
you're like oh you don't understand like
all my time at MIT was figured out how
to solve math problems other people
couldn't it but if you say oh I'm a
writer like actually there's some like
interesting prestige in that like well
wait you can do that as you're living
like you must be doing something
interesting you must be artistic you
must be interesting uh and so maybe
that's what I think about that's how
I've been thinking about it recently is
finding you know hacking that system of
my brain so think about these decisions
is there if I change my situation could
I have a way of describing it that uh
and and so I don't know what it would be
I mean you're writing a book I don't
know how's that going by the way I don't
know if you're liking that process or
not yeah yeah so yeah on this on this
writer Point um this was uh
probably about two years into my YouTube
career when things started going really
well so that was you know I've been
doing been doing a for five years
now so about two years in
um I was still working as a doctor I was
sort of YouTube channel was on like a
quarter of a million subscribers the
revenue was starting to sort of 3x what
I was making as a doctor and I was like
oh my God there's really something here
but then that thing in my mind was the
question that you that you mentioned
earlier was what does this look like 10
years from now 15 years from now and my
solution to this was writer because and
again I was thinking of people like you
people like Ryan people like Tim Ferriss
even uh who like the it it feels like
being a writer is something you can do
when you're like 50 years old uh but I
think of when I'm 50 years old I'm
unlikely to be looking at a camera and
being like what's up guys welcome back
to my YouTube channel or whatever that
or whatever that looks like yeah um so
I'd kind of had this vague plan of okay
I think the evolution of the internet
thought leader is to get the book the
book if it can hit a bestseller list
cool whatevs
um that unlocks speaking opportunities
which unlocks the next book and that
felt to me like it could be a game that
I could play you know the infinite game
um I'd be quite content living that
lifestyle of just like hey I get to
write books every every few years and as
long as the system around it of like
selling stuff or doing a podcast getting
sponsorships or or if I kept my expenses
low enough that would be able to sustain
a full-time life style so here's I'm
going to make another suggestion for you
like if I'm thinking about describing
you well first of all I would I think to
say YouTuber is super narrow like to me
I see uh media entrepreneur
media model like this is what Ryan
Holliday is this is what Tim Ferriss is
right this is it's what Bill Simmons did
building out the ringer right so I'm
looking around at people that have let's
say a presence online how many actually
have teams that you meet you know like
you do in an office to like go over your
sketch or whatever it's a new media
entrepreneur New Media Mogul media
entrepreneur that what you're really
building is a new type of media company
where there's uh video content there's
audio content there's interactive
digital content books might be a part of
that but that's something interesting
your your you you have your finger on
the pulse of an emerging new segments of
the media Market that I think are going
to be massive you have a head start
you're in the top one half of one
percent of people working on this so I'm
wondering if that's the answer to the
question it's like yeah I was a doctor
and I left to do a media startup I'm a
media entrepreneur because I think
there's all of this disruption happening
and you know we have this big audiences
and all this Innovation and we're
figuring things out yeah you know I
think that's a good Insight um I've not
quite thought of it in that way
um but one word I have been sort of you
know me and my team have been floating
it around is like instead of media
entrepreneur like Creator entrepreneur
or like Creator preneur which is a bit
of a weird Mash of mesh of those things
where I think increasingly the world is
moving more towards uh
individuals well you know the Creator
economy I would say that you're a you
know would be fair to describe you as a
Creator as well because books and
podcasts and blogs and articles and and
all that kind of stuff and there's this
sort of new wave of Creator
entrepreneurs the sort of creators who
who then build a team around them and
create like either a lifestyle Business
Like Mine broadly or a very performance
heavy business like someone like Mr
Beast with a team of like 100 people and
this whole like Empire
um that feels like something kind of
interesting but it it feels like we're
sort of at the start of that where the
Creator economy has been around for
several years now but there's very few
people doing it with this whole like
building a business around around the
thing
yeah well I think a lot of innovation is
happening I mean something I'm thinking
about right now or actually I'm doing
right now is sort of spinning off you
know a lot of my writing recently has
been about various aspects of what I
summarized with the phrase the Deep life
so my recent books my recent articles
the things I'm writing now a lot of it
not all of it but a lot of is really
about ways to to take back control of
your life and how you spend your time
and work but also in your life outside
of work and and defeating distractions
and being more intentional and billions
more meaningful interesting whatever
work in professional lives is uh I'm
building a a home for this
that is distinct from just me as Cal
Newport the writer because I also do
other things I I publish academic papers
I write about other topics I do more
more hardcore techno criticism and so
this is something I'm trying to figure
out right now is that we this portal the
deeplife.com is you know a month or two
away but it's going to be the online
home for that movement and it's now
suddenly I can the various stuff content
I'm creating around that can have a home
but also other people can help provide
content for that and it can be its own
stand-alone entity in some sort and what
I'm realizing is none there's no
playbook for any of this
you know it's all all this is up in the
air so that's why I keep coming back to
you you're running a successful media
business
which which I think is really
interesting
um because obviously something really
interesting is happening now this this
when you distribute I've been trying to
work through this theories but when you
when you distribute the means of
production for media so now many more
people have access to means of
production for a certain type of media
it generates a lot of innovation it
happened with text first with the web
now suddenly almost anyone could produce
text it could be universally consumed
that happened next for audio because the
tech hurdle there I think was was easier
so now we see uh the the business model
around podcasting blowing up because but
the combination of iPhones uh wireless
internet plus uh podcast technology like
this is comparable to radio so now
suddenly you could have broad
competition in the radio space and then
now it's happening with with video uh
YouTube helped enable that better
cameras better better production and now
that's just starting to figure out how
to what happens when we distribute the
means of production for uh video media
which is going to be the biggest of all
because that's the in traditional media
that's the most successful medium of all
is is Visual and we have no idea where
where that's going to unfold other than
there's going to be a lot of innovation
the pi of available revenue is going to
grow and be more widely distributed and
no one really knows where where that's
going to end up I mean I have to assume
the YouTube aesthetic what's emerged
right now is just step one five or ten
years from now I'm not quite sure what
this this world of distributed uh videos
can look like but I think it's going to
consolidate in the the sort of these
small to medium-sized firms I think the
sort of 100 million dollars 40 person
creation network is going to be the key
unit of the future of content production
this sort of this sort of these these
minor production houses I don't know if
that's all gonna be true all I know is
there's a lot of churna innovation
happening right now yeah
yeah no definitely um yeah this is
something I do I do think about a lot um
anytime we're doing kind of quarterly
planning or anything for the business
and and for the team people keep on
asking me hey where are we going what's
the vision and stuff and I'm like partly
I have no idea we're just making it up
as we go along but then I do think huh
what does what would it look like
um you know a few a few months ago I was
thinking okay we you know we've got a
team of like 20-ish people you'll be
good to get our revenues up to like 10
million and then expand out into like a
space where we can rent out Studios to
other creators in London and we can form
this little London creators Hub and then
maybe we'll go up to 40 people and
and then
I don't know I found that
I mean I I probably did this wrong but I
found my calendar just being
chock-a-block with management related
stuff rather than uh creation and
reading and writing which is the thing
that I actually care about
um and then we kind of did a little bit
of downsizing moved to some Freelancers
and now when I think of that model of
like a team of 40 people and like a big
company or big-ish company I feel oh
that sounds like pretty bad I'd actually
quite like the life where I've just got
maybe 10 people on the team or like 12
people on the team and we're all remote
and I get to travel around the world and
do my writing for four hours a day or
whatever whatever that looks like so I
feel like there's a little bit of this
um this tension between
I kind of want to live a sort of Ryan
holiday-esque Lifestyle on a farm versus
I know that the world is moving towards
building these media companies and I'm
kind of resisting The Lure of oh just
yeah yeah all right so that's
interesting so here's the other yes
let's put that data point on the other
end of the spectrum sure though Ryan's
busier than all of us so we won't let's
not use CMOS he has the farm but he also
has the bookstore in like 90 other
things yeah but I think the right
examples is uh Ferris and Rogan it's
like Ferris and Rogan's model is this
one thing I'm doing is very successful
let's do it at a really high level it
generates a lot of money and so let's
just be and build a really interesting
lifestyle about it like think about like
Tim has really stop the other types of
things he stopped the book writing you
know I interviewed him about this uh and
you can he played the interview that I
did of him on his feet so if you want to
find that you find out his feed not mine
and he was really talking about how
books burnt him out because he was he
was writing door stops he was writing
500 pages so yeah and the podcast and
investing was burning him out he was
doing a lot of Angel Investing uh Siege
Fates and he just stopped all of that
and said I'm just going to do the
podcast as like an escape because it was
just one thing it was more focused it
was more more immediate
um and then they kill it with it because
they get these massive cpms and have a
really big audience and then Rogan I
guess is the classic example of that is
he's like this thing is doing well I'm
just going to do this
like I and he's not interested in all
the rest of his time is as far as I can
tell just by second hand right it's just
very intentionally allocated to things
that are optional optional activities
that he enjoys
um that have no so maybe we should put a
I like this we're kind of we're working
on an ontology here so we have Bill
Simmons
on one side of this build the ringer
sell it for 200 million dollars like
that's where the that's where the
capital is Flowing on the other side you
have Ferris you have Rogan which is uh
figure out the thing you do well uh
taking advantage of new media
opportunities to be able to build an
empire in a place where you wouldn't
have been able to 15 years ago get it
get it down to a science really enjoy
what you're doing have you know do that
really well but also generate copious
autonomy because you know hey you're I
don't know if you're doing 4 million a
year on a podcast
and that's the only thing you're doing I
guess there's a there's an affluence
argument here like are you less happy
than Bill Simmons with the his the 70
million cut he got from the sale of the
ringer but who is now the head of
content At You Know audio content at
Spotify and overseen and all these
things and documentaries I think so
that's actually like a really fair
question and maybe the answer is it
depends who you are like Bill Simmons is
probably happy doing that but Tim would
be miserable and Simmons would be
miserable if he was Tim so I guess maybe
that's the question is where do we fall
on that Spectrum no exactly yeah I think
um there's a there's a there's a blog
post you wrote uh I can't remember the
times that one I probably like 2010 or
something and you said something like uh
the the advice that you give to students
when they're trying to figure out what
to do with their careers is to begin
with the lifestyle in mind and reverse
engineer the career from that rather
than hey I did an economics degree
therefore uh private Equity hedge funds
or Investment Banking are my three
options and you end up going down one of
these one of these routes
um and that that post really Vibe with
me because I think it helped it made me
think Hmm
if I were to begin with a lifestyle in
mind does that in fact actually look
like the big Media Company
um the answer is probably not but then
another part of me was like am I just
feeling
uh
am I just bullshitting myself and just
like setting my ambitions lower because
I am afraid of the work that it would
take to build said Media company and try
and try and go big and I'm just content
to wallow in my own mediocrity of like
oh just write four hours a day and then
I'm happy with life I don't need to make
that much money and you do you get what
I'm getting at yeah I don't think you're
dilute so first of all I love that post
so yeah Lifestyle Center Career planning
I think is such a critical idea
um especially for young people trying to
figure out in college I wrote that while
at a graduation ceremony for my sister
so I was thinking about graduate
graduation advice yeah and you and it it
has to be the right answer for how you
figure out your career which is you get
the image of the lifestyle you want at
whatever point you know in the future
and you make it super tangible like you
can you can feel it you can smell it you
can see it but not getting specific at
all about what your work is like are you
in the countryside are you in a city is
it you know you you're you're at the
Bohemian bar in the in the Lower East
Side and and around all these artists
are you in a field and you've been out
in the sun and like you know whatever
working on your Trails like what is it
is it very social are you in a small
town are you what are you up in the
mountains like get that really clear and
then say great let me work backwards now
to figure out how do I get there with my
work
right and and I think that's such a
critical way of thinking about things
because hey it's not just hey Follow
Your Passion or something like this
because the right answer might be I'm
going to go to medical school so that I
can be uh sort of get these Nightingale
shifts where I work uh three times a
week one week out of the month or
something like that or work for three
months and it's and it's the highest
hourly rate I can get and then I can
spend the whole summer in the Canary
Islands like it it can lead you to
really interesting places I think it's
the way to do it and the reason why I
think you in particular are not you're
not deluding yourself into you know
avoiding the difficulties of ambition is
that
a lot of people when they do this
exercise it is 100 clear they want that
they really crave that activity and work
right so I think it's a really clear
personality type thing that that if you
are the type of person whose ideal
lifestyle does involve I've got a team
I'm making moves it's super really clear
if you talk to those people and I have
because you know this is my framework
and I run that framework past there's a
lot of people who are like I love the
idea of activity I don't want to be
doing something I want people you know I
want to be at the center of attention I
want people that are on my team I want
to be I love that action the sociality
the the some people love that so
if you don't feel it unambiguous of
course that's what I want to do
then I think that's really meaningful
and I'll tell you I think I'm like you
which is why the way I am logistically
handling the business aspect of all this
career is right now I have a half day
rule
one half day a week it has to fit in
that if it can't if something can't fit
in that then I can't do it and my goal
down the line is make that one day a
week
and that's it and and so and that's how
I've done my whole with the podcast
everything else it's whatever fits in a
half day a week that I put aside on my
calendar that's what I can do and as I
get good at something we hire people to
do something that frees up more time I
can try to add something else but I'm
constrained by that because I think like
you
I would have misery
I would find misery if every single day
it was like rock and rolling let's go
this the calendar you mentioned your
calendar chock full of uh I got heart
palpitations I hate that right so for me
it's like okay one half day a week all
in what can we do with that get better
improve this hire that let's fix this
and outside of that I don't want to
think about a thing about the business
because I think I'm with you and that's
the compromise I've come up with nice
yeah I've I've landed on uh one day a
week where I just do my YouTube stuff so
every Thursday is YouTube day perfect we
start the Thursday with usually just a
vague notion of uh maybe we'll film
videos ABC in the morning without all
right cool what are the videos are going
to be and uh yesterday filmed I think
three three videos they're like yeah
cool that's content for the next three
weeks sorted
um and that and that feels like a good
place to be because to come back to the
book thing and I'd love to get your
thoughts on this
um that now unlocks basically every
morning for three four hours from nine
till 12 30 nine till one is blocked out
protected book writing time and then
most afternoons are generally free-ish
to you know either be in the studio and
chat to the team and brainstorm some
ideas if that's what I feel like doing
or just doing like a whole day on the
book
um and as of this morning I handed in
the really crappy first draft to our
editors at penguin and MacMillan and now
about my age and I'm just waiting
because but like some of it is like
fleshed out some of it is still notes
and bullet points some of it is still
like I was feeling so bad about this but
then my agent replied she was like don't
worry canning in the first draft is
always really really messy it does not
need to look look pretty oh what what's
been your um your experience of the
whole first draft and then and then
beyond
yeah well I just handed in uh a week ago
the first 20 000 words of my newest book
so we're in the same place I haven't
heard back yet now look I mean I've been
at it for a while because I did my first
uh what's the math on this my first book
deal I signed right after I turned 21.
so like I've been I've been through it a
bunch of times and it's so it's less
it's it's a little bit less what
uh 40. oh okay now have you been into
the toilet 20 years solid 20 years yeah
I've been I've been I've been at the
game for yeah for 20 years yeah I wrote
my first book my my last year at
University and then
um so I've been doing it for yeah I've
been doing for a little while my method
everyone has a different method what I
tend to do is hand in like big chunks
early on so to see because for me it's a
hard I have finding the voice for a book
is usually takes me some time and so I
want to make sure I have it right so
like I handed in 18 000 words last
Friday
um a critical part of the book and it's
like I want to stop there and talk to my
editor and then if if if she's on board
with with that and once we get that
right then I'm gonna have the confidence
to to go and and write the next 60 or or
whatever however many are however many
are going on so so that that's been my
been my process now I'm also right now
writing the the one of the first
chapters in the book is more idea like
and uh I pitched the ideas of New Yorker
article so I'm I'm writing it for the
New Yorker now then I can use it for the
first draft of the book so that's
another one of my tricks if something
has to be it's subtle and it has to be
really well researched I let the
pressure of the New Yorker like force me
to do the work because it's like you got
to get it right it's really hard
um so that's like that's where I am now
I'm and it's like today this morning
um like finish the last technical piece
of that art it's a big five six thousand
word Beast
um finished the last technical Beast of
that this morning and so like by Monday
I'll probably probably have that thing
have that thing done but that's what I
do pieces I do it in pieces
what is your if you know let's say it's
uh four hours in the morning and you've
got your writing time what is that what
does that look like I guess
as specifically as you could possibly be
because I I'm I'm looking for any magic
bullet that will help solve my problems
well okay so I I
spend a lot of time doing richly
detailed annotated outlines
right so like to me that's really
important I gotta get if I'm working on
a big section I got to get that feel
right like this and that and this and
these are the examples and that I'll
work on not on foot often I find on
foot's the right way to do that and I'll
spend hours and hours over many days
just coming back to thinking about
structure idea structuring and do this I
did this and that and this all right so
then when I'm writing
what I'm doing is implementing that plan
so when I'm writing in the morning like
this morning if you came into to my
study and like watched me writing it's
uh I use scrivener yep so I have you
know uh dozens of notes where I've
copied in notes or this or that on one
Pane and and the uh and the the main
draft in the other and then I'll have a
stack of books that whatever books I'm
polling from for that for that
particular piece and then it's just I'm
climbed one sentence at a time
you know like that that look this up and
I'm all about pacing this has been my
big thing recently uh in the last few
years I'm trying to up my writing
qualities it's a lot of pacing it's like
take your time get it right you know
slow and steady definitely like a slow
and steady wins the race type of type of
vibe get it right get because I think
that density comes through it comes
through in the writing if it was
a lot was trying to get done here in two
hours and it shows in the writing you
know you're kind of you're you're
working your way around the tricky
points and I try to and a lot of this
came to me writing for the New Yorker
helped on this is you got to have
consistent density like you know what
you're saying everything is based on
it's been thought through you're citing
the right things it's you're taking your
time
um and so it's just polling sentence by
sentence let's go let's go I do I do it
all on this you know small MacBook which
is this one is you know two years old
but there's no you can't see any of the
letters uh most alerts on the keyboard
have been rubbed off from just writing
you know like just just rock and rolling
like all the notes you take all the
writing all the editing
um and then the other thing I'll say
about my process is uh
it's all gut for me so I I will often
finish something and just and my gut
says it's not singing and I will go back
and do
drastic surgery I do this all the time I
I really trust my gut where I'm like I I
it's it's uh I physically feel
uncomfortable
and and about a draft
and to me that it's the structure
there's nothing to do with the craft of
the sentences the structure of the ideas
is not right
um and that makes me physically
uncomfortable and then I will I will go
back and do drastic surgery on things
you know and and just to give you like
an example of this a couple weeks ago I
published a New Yorker piece on Tick
Tock and Facebook and what Tick Tock
means about social media
after that article had been sent to copy
editing I was feeling so physically
uncomfortable and I was on vacation at
the time I was like this is just not
right and I I just told my wife and kids
like pretend I'm not here and just put
my head down and essentially like
completely rework the whole thing
and and and and then suddenly it felt
right and that's like very common for me
I'm like this isn't right uh and then
what it is it feels it nice yeah that
that very much Vibes with my experience
um in that
so I've been working on mine for about
18 months now and we're now at the point
where you know I had it in the first
draft but a lot of it there was a lot of
outlining initially and then a lot of
like just sort of uh trying to get vomit
any kind of words out onto the page and
in the process of vomiting words out
onto the page I feel like my ideas got
refined to the point where now when I
when I went back to it to just do the
first round of editing before handing it
into the editor officially I found it
really helpful to actually Zoom back out
um I went on a mirror white interactive
whiteboard thing and just put loads of
Post-it notes on there and basically
drafted out the outline again
and thinking okay that leads to that
leads to that oh hang on there's a bit
of a hole in the logic over there okay
let's figure out how we're going to
flash that and bit and sort of moving
sort of Post-it notes around this
interactive whiteboard thing was just so
helpful
um and then I just translated once I was
happy with the argument I just
translated each one into a little thing
on scrivener and after that right cool
back back
and I felt like okay cool and at least
the argument makes sense the point a
leads to B leaves to series to D and
there's no random leaps of logic where I
can get away with it in a YouTube video
where no one's going to think about it
but like in in writing it's like oh I
feel like the argument needs to be a bit
more refined for it to feel legit well
and I think people and I think people uh
they don't realize the importance of
that especially in idea writing like how
much of idea writing is that
subconscious feel the reader has of as
their mind is piecing together what you
say if it all fits regardless of whether
they think it's interesting regardless
whether they agree if it all fits their
mind is going to give them a different
reaction than if it doesn't quite fit
and if it doesn't quite fit
it feels weird to people and they can't
even really put their finger on it
they're like I just don't like this it's
why by the way you know probably from
your your medical training which there's
a lot of precision to that is probably
helping you hear a lot because you think
this this has to fit this has to put
together my training as a mathematician
helps me a lot in idea writing because I
do proofs uh for a living as an academic
work everything has to fit like
literally so I construct my my arguments
like a proof like if this doesn't fit
from this and if you didn't mention this
here and there uh no QED yep it makes a
big difference even if the reader
doesn't put their finger on it directly
this is why some stuff if you read like
online feels amateurish and some stuff
feels really compelling is the the
amateur stuff is people are putting down
here's a bunch of points I thought of
that I think are interesting but they
don't click all together in some sort of
cohesive way and it just reads very
different
how do you think about this uh where
we're going deep into sort of
self-indulgent territory here on on my
pod but that's fine how do you think
about the balance of
let me say the things that are
sufficiently counter-intuitive and novel
to get a dopamine hit from the audience
versus let me say the things I need to
say in order for my argument to make
sense do those things ever Clash in your
mind
I mean yeah because we we both are in
this space we're we're you know I'm
definitely known for contrarianism I
mean I would say for me
what I'm always looking for is an
understanding of something in the world
that makes sense to me explains things
that otherwise didn't make sense before
and is generative so I can then use this
to like make decisions going forward or
understand new things that arrive in the
world and there's like a real great
feeling when you get there now there's
often a
contrarianism to it because look I grew
up immersed of the the sort of the great
idea writers of the of the 90s and 2000s
I was you know immersed in Gladwell and
uh Johnson and I really like some of the
stuff Clive Thompson was doing back then
um but the really great idea writers and
Gladwell was a master of this it was
it wasn't contrarianism in the sense of
you thought this but it's the opposite
instead it's you don't know anything
about this but once you do all of that
makes sense in a new light
like that's what that's what I love so
if I can convince myself like okay I I
have a a working model of that explains
whatever that explains the Dynamics in
the social media space and and why
what's going on with Tick Tock or this
or that or I've Dynamic understanding
career satisfaction or or what's going
on in the workplace and why we're so
distracted why would that persist why
would we persist with something that was
was so low low productivity when I get a
model that works and the pieces click
together that's what I love and then
it's like it's contrarianism but it's
not it's different than I think takism
which you get a lot online especially in
Click culture which is look at look at
my take you know I've got my hot take
where all you're trying to do is have a
headline that grabs people's attention
and you're trying to make your hot take
that to me is a lot less interesting
um I mean a lot of the hot take writing
online right now that's trying to
attract uh clicks especially more like
the news and commentary space often it's
usually it's not even contrarian anymore
it's more just like
we all belong to the same tribe let me
take my turn dunking on the on the enemy
and then everyone kind of applaud like
oh that was a that was a good like you
got a good punch in there that was
really kind of smart and snarky and then
someone else steps up it's like well
look at my take you know yeah so and so
is the worst since you know whatever ah
so not interesting all right so so
anyways that's how that's how I come at
it and I mean I don't know a lot of the
details of your book but it sounds like
it's kind of in the same Pace you have
your
your ideas you're explaining various
things I mean obviously I think your
thoughts on on productivity have a lot
of this too it's like here's my model
you know this is the way I think about
things uh and I think that's really
fulfilling yeah no it's really fun like
I get a I get a big kick out of like yes
the framework makes sense it's like
coming coming up with like how do I make
the framework in three parts because two
is not that satisfying like three oh yes
it works and it explains all these
different things and when I teach my
YouTuber Academy and teach people how to
do content and stuff I try my best to
essentially framework if I like I would
when back when I went back when I was
teaching medical students around like
hey really there's only three different
types of hemolytic malignancies that you
uh that you need to know about one two
and three and now we can break those
into three more and if there's something
satisfying about connecting ideas or
simplifying ideas like that in a way
that is generative as you said like
helps you actually make decisions moving
forward
yeah and and just to throw out one other
thing that like non-non-professional
idea writers also get wrong as well is
you as the writer don't have to handle
all the caveats so it's like another
issue you have like if if it's a common
misconception people have where they'll
be like well but you didn't mention this
and what about people who are in this
situation and the reason is if you're in
interpersonal conversation with another
human
your course are going to caveat whatever
advice you're giving to kind of match
that person right like if you're if
you're a runner and giving running
advice and someone has like a knee brace
song is that a knee injury you're going
to sort of caveat it well you know like
you're not gonna I'm not going to tell
you like go run six miles a day or
whatever but in in Broad audience idea
writing you don't do that like you have
a framework that's interesting it's
compelling it's going to open up a lot
of thinking help people understand new
things they're going to take that and
integrate it into their own experience
and they're gonna have to caveat and
modify it and like of course the running
advice isn't supposed to apply to the
person who's in the knee brace like they
they'll figure that all out but it's
like a a a cohesive coherent
intellectual schema that they can
integrate into their life and that's
exciting and they build from it and
integrate it to other things they know
so it's like in professional idea
writing you take your swing and you make
it as exciting as possible and good and
interesting and coherent and you don't
bother explaining but here's 10 here's
10 cases where you know it might not be
this and these people might not be able
to use them don't worry about that and
so I think idea writers get this
critique from individuals a lot well you
didn't talk about this situation because
again I think that's the Gap when you're
dealing one-on-one with people of course
you're going to caveat whatever you're
saying to their situation when you're
writing one to a million it makes the
writing bogged down and boring and weird
and uh self-protective and and muggy you
know it's not good right yeah you know
take the swing throw the take the big
swing you can other people will other
people can modify it a little bit that's
another thing it takes some getting used
to is you have to it's like you're
simplifying yeah a little bit that's a
really good tip this is something I'm
definitely struggling with right now and
I think
um sort of the the YouTube videos that I
put out so you know the other day put
out something around um
oh I was I was I was a it was it was a
collaboration with a friend of mine who
was thinking of quitting their job and I
was like okay cool you know let's figure
out let's try and riff and come up with
a framework for how to decide when to
quit your job in terms of like how much
income you have coming in expenses side
hustle income or blur all this
opportunity cost expected value all of
the things and the video did really well
people really liked it and there was one
comment saying this video was extremely
ableist as a disabled person who
struggles to focus I couldn't possibly
do any of this stuff
and part of me was like yeah you're kind
of right like I mean but also part of it
was like um you know maybe I should have
caveat a bit like hey this relies on you
actually having the time and the energy
to do but then the whole video becomes a
series of caveats and I think I'm
struggling with that in the book as well
to think oh but I I can think of like
eight different objections to this idea
here uh and I don't want to have space
to write a contra to all eight of them
so yeah yeah and I mean I I I I I I I
call this like the the the blind caveat
rule or something like this it's like if
if you're if you're writing a book about
a painter or something like that and
like well this is Cezanne was really
working with color and doing this and
that you don't have to bother adding the
caveat of course if you're blind
uh there's like information about what
these paintings look like is not going
to be as useful because people already
know that like they'll add that they'll
add that copy I know it's the broken leg
the broken leg principle right like if
you're writing a book about running
training you don't have to caveat it you
know if you're if you have a broken leg
uh you're not gonna be able to do this
training the people with the broken legs
know they're not gonna be able to do
this train but again I think what comes
back to here is it's actually well
intentioned I mean some of this stuff is
cynical it's you know I whatever like
we're in a world of there's a whole
there's a whole thing to talk about
about how the various critical theories
in Academia have pervaded culture so
there's a there's a tone of critique in
those theories that have now filtered
into culture so there's a lot of now
social standing from critique blah blah
blah there's a whole
self-indulgent uh rant academic rant to
give about that but actually like a lot
of that type of critique is well
intentioned like what you're talking
about there because again if I'm not a
writer or someone who does YouTube
videos for hundreds of thousands of
people or millions of people my
framework reference is talking to
someone and if I was talking to someone
whose life was really not and they're
having a lot of difficulties and they
their life wasn't in order and I was
giving them advice about like yeah then
you gotta like
look at the expected value and do this
and that it would be weird and insulting
and kind of mean you know like this is
not someone who's who's they're in a
situation where they can't take this
advice why would you possibly be talking
about this stuff when someone's not in a
situation to take it and so that's our
frame I think our frame as humans is one
on one and it's very different than one
to a million and so yeah I think the the
it it when you shift to the broadcast
frame it's like yeah obviously a lot of
people this is not for but but there's a
lot of people who can take this and and
work with it and so like let's let's put
that put that out there but I get the
same thing all the time um how can I do
deep work if dot dot dot and there's a
lot of things you can put on the other
side of that dot dot dot and and you
know I get that all day long and it's
like it's true but it would be the first
50 pages of my book if I had to go
through it you know and it would be such
boring weird
self-indulgent writing if it's like let
me let me talk about it's like obviously
you know how can I do deep work if I'm a
telegraph operator and my job is to at
Western Union to to take papers and do
Telegraph I can't do deep work there
it's like yeah okay you got me I mean
this is the theory is not valid like I
don't know what you want me to say but
anyways I feel you feel your pain
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by wework now this is particularly
exciting for me because I have been a
full paying customer of wework for the
last two years now I discovered it
during you know when the pandemic was in
on the verge of being lifted and I spent
like the whole year just sort of sitting
in my room making YouTube videos but
then I discovered wework and I was a
member me and Angus my team members we
were members of the wework in Cambridge
and they have like hundreds of other
locations worldwide as well and it was
incredible because we had this fantastic
beautifully designed office space to go
to to work and we found ourselves like
every day just at nine o'clock in the
morning just going to wework because it
was a way nicer experience working from
the co-working space than it was just
sitting at home working these days what
me and everyone in my team has is the
all access pass which means you're not
tied to a specific wework location but
it means you can use any of their
several hundred co-working spaces around
London around the UK and also around the
world and one of the things I really
love about the co-working setup is that
it's fantastic as a bit of a change of
scenery so these days I work from home
I've got the studio at home but if I
need to get some focused writing work
done and I've been I'm feeling a bit
drained just sitting at my desk all day
I'll just pop over to the local wework
which is about a 10 minute walk from
where I am I'll take my laptop up with
me I've got some free coffee from there
I'll get a few snacks and it's just such
a great Vibe and you get to meet cool
people I made a few friends through
meeting them at wework and it's just
really nice being an environment almost
like a library but kind of nicer because
there's like a little bit of soft music
in the background and there's other kind
of startup Bros and creators and stuff
in in there as well and it's just my
absolute favorite co-working space of
all time it's super easy to book a desk
or book a conference room using the app
and it's a great place to meet up with
team members if you're going to
collaborate and you'll live in different
places they've got unlimited tea and
coffee and herbal teas and drinks on tap
and they've also got various kind of
after work events that happen like happy
hours and yoga and a few other exercise
type things and you can also take in
guests so often when guests will come
over to visit I'll say hey let's pop
into wework and we'll just work from
there for the whole day and then we'll
go out for dinner sometime in the
evening anyway if you're looking for a
co-working space for you or your team
then I'd 100 recommend wework like I
said I've been a pain customer for
theirs for the last two years which is
why it's particularly exciting that
they're now sponsoring this episode and
if you want to get 50 off your first
booking then do head over to we.com
forward slash Ali and you can use the
coupon code Ali at checkout Ali to get
50 of your first booking so thank you so
much wework for sponsoring this episode
I'm just curious what sort of
criticism do you get and how do you how
do you deal with it like I I've Heard
lots of criticisms of Malcolm Gladwell
of like oh but he's cherry picking
whatever story to suit his ends and then
when he wrote talking to talking to
strangers and had a whole thing about
sexual assault in there I was like oh
hello that's going to get a lot of
criticism from people who are like oh
Jerry the cherry picking of data cherry
picking stories that's not how it
actually happened he's only saying that
because it's interesting
um what sort of stuff do you get and I'm
I'm just I'm just very curious because
I'm trying to sort of preempt to what
sort of criticism I'm gonna get and I
feel like my stuff is going to be more
in line with yours than in line with
with gladwells I mean it it depends on
the on the content area because because
I I write in a bunch of content areas
but okay so here's a few Classics and
some of these have changed
um it's like you know obviously in my
techno criticism I did a lot of thinking
and writing about social media and as
impact on on human flourishing was what
sort of a an early critic of social
media the only person My Generation not
to have a social media account uh I I
used to get before disliking social
media became mainstream I used to get a
lot of like how can you possibly write
about something that you don't heavily
use so that was a big one
which I thought was weird right because
a lot of great journalists for example
covered the various drug epidemics in
the U.S without having to go heavily use
all those drugs to write about it I mean
did people have written books about
serial killing without having to
actually go serial kills yeah so I used
to get that but I don't get I don't get
that as uh I don't get that as much with
deep work one I get a lot now
and it's taking me a while to try to
um
untangle as I used to I I get a lot like
but how can I do deep work if
um like I have kids
or child care or deep work is great if
you have someone at home to take care of
other things
that's a very common one and for a while
it it confused me because I was like
well wait a second this framework was
about
you know you're at the office for eight
hours a day
during that time that you're there uh
you should spend more of those hours
in undistracted work versus more
distracted work so it was about like the
ratio of what you spent your time on
like during the day when you're at work
I was like it's not and and so I used to
be confused I was like well what does
this have to do I'm not asking people to
work more I'm not asking like I'm trying
to understand what's going on here and I
think what's happening with that
critique is there is
um a leap and I think this is telling
and and Earnest so it's not like I'm
this is critical I think there's a leap
from
deep work uh deep work
can produce like more impressive
accomplishments that gets associated
with ambition and that gets associated
with the sort of all in ambitious like
I'm working all day trying to crush it
you know
changing the world so there's this weird
I think Elite people are making in their
minds between what I thought was a
pretty dry argument which is like when
you're at your office instead of like
going back and forth your inbox all day
you know like do that first and then do
this for a long time and then go back to
your inbox instead of interspersing like
it's a very dry technical argument about
how you spend the time you're already
spending working right
um and it became and and I think it
became wrapped up in people's minds
about a life of ambition and going after
really cool things and a frustration of
like not everyone is has the like the
flexibility or autonomy or or just
energy left to do that and so that's
that's an interesting critique right and
I'm still trying to pull that pull that
one apart yeah deep work to people I
think means
like excessive ambitious self-oriented
Elon Musk changed the world type work
yeah so I think yeah that's a common one
that's out there too I think I I get
that a lot and then the third one I get
which is just accurate is you're a dude
and especially like you don't really
fully understand not being a dude
and I'm like fair enough that's fair
enough right like I mean just the way
like guys very you know stereotypically
speaking process a lot of things think
about a lot of things the things they
that they're concerned with is specific
and I think it comes through and and I
have a lot of women in my audience but
they also are like you talk about this a
little differently than we do and to
which I tip my cap I'm like that's true
yeah definitely I guess um this your
your second uh criticism this sort of
deep work becomes associated with
ambition hustle and and stuff
um how broadly what's your uh what's
your hot take on uh on the phrase toxic
productivity these days
yeah well I mean this is in my work on
slow productivity comes out of this
um the some degree
uh yeah so there's a there's a real anti
productivity movement going on right now
but it's it's a little bit confusing
I've wrote about I wrote several
articles about this for the New Yorker
trying to
figure out what's going on
like with with the anti-productivity
movement
um and I think there's a couple
different things in there like one
there's this there's a straw I think
what now has become a straw man this
like hustle culture and maybe it's not a
straw man because I'm not on social
media so maybe this still exists you
would know better
um but I think it's become a straw man
this idea of everyone is saying work
harder do more things and I'm the Bold
social critic who says you know maybe
not whereas I actually see the opposite
everyone is saying like we're too
overloaded like we should do less stuff
like me time find yourself like I don't
know where maybe it's just Gary
vaynerchuk's like the last person left I
don't know where this is but there's
this notion of like there's this big
culture that's pushing
um even outside of professional sphere
this like Instagram hustle culture of
like you gotta but and that might exist
again I don't use social media so maybe
there's a lot of that going on still of
of you know Jocko I'm up at 4am and you
got to uh you have to as well though
even Jocko says like I'm weird I I have
low sleep demands and I don't recommend
this for other people
um so there's that and then I think
there's another thing going on which to
me is more interesting
which is I think knowledge work in
general is pretty broken I think the way
we run offices is very haphazard and
unintentional and it's it's
unnecessarily exhausting I think we're
terrible at organizing groups of people
using their brains to add value to
information and people are exhausted
because we run offices dumbly and the
pandemic made it much worse so there's a
few things that happened with the
pandemic that made the systemic issues
we already had which were productivity
issues like the way we assign organize
and keep track of work is just Bonkers
and office work it's just rock and roll
and email and slack I don't know here's
a media invite let's just hope it works
out and the pandemic made it work
because it generated a bunch of new work
and reduced the effectiveness of
collaboration because it was all video
we couldn't grab people in the hallways
and kind of push things over the edge so
I think the other half of and this is
probably the core engine of
anti-productivity culture is
people in office jobs are exhausted by
how stupidly we run offices and so they
kind of vaguely just like uh
productivity like stop asking me to do
more work like my work's exhausting me
and then there's a small sliver there's
my cynical thing there's a small sliver
of like very online people for which the
productivity movement is like their
online well-educated professional
writers with sub Stacks who um who used
to you know quite left of center and
want to they love the idea of like
being part of a labor movement
themselves they sort of look look with
some Envy at the big sort of industrial
labor movements the union movements
these big successful uh movements from
the left they get have workers against
the capitalist overlords I think there's
some sense of like oh I want that too so
we kind of invent this notion of this
mustache twirling uh managers are like
trying to force us to do too much work
and we're fighting back and we're Norma
Ray and so there's a little bit of that
going on too so I think all three of
those things are going the sort of the
the straw man culture of like I want to
fight against the straw man the fact at
work we don't know what productivity
means in the office our definition is
stupid I think people get that and that
just gets simplified as enough of this
productivity stuff and then you have the
sort of sub stackers that are just you
know want to be uh Cesar Chavez and and
and are trying to conflate and they're
trying to you can tell this type because
they make a living writing but when
they're talking about their issues and
their exhaustion we'll try to work in
the Amazon labor union
uh debates into their like try to mix
those two together like yeah me and the
Amazon workers in the warehouse like
we're all kind of fighting management
and so there's some of that type going
on we have to like pull all those
threads apart to really understand
what's going on yeah I definitely agree
with you on the the whole
stromaanization of the hustle hustle
culture thing even Gary vaynerchuk's has
stopped peddling that narrative many
years ago uh but it's still he's been
become painted with that brush and now
it's sort of lab bastard it's like oh
but like garyvee says you should work
all the time Curry B is like his whole
thing is like hey look man you know just
do whatever makes you happy
um uh I think that that was that was a
super interesting that was a random
Instagram reel that a friend of mine
actually posted where the caption which
I just sort of chuckled at where the
caption was hey it's Friday so I'm gonna
close my laptop at four rather than five
just uh because my corporate Overlord
does not own my time
and like it was like okay cool fair
enough
um but then part of me was just like a
bit confused by that because
it's like
this person is choosing to work well has
has chosen to work in a job which is
famously demanding I.E one of the
management consulting firms
and it's like saying that yeah it's an
act of self-care to stick it to my
corporate Overlord and quit working an
hour early yeah and I was I was just
like what's what's going on there but
because I I I guess for me in this
position of privilege is like my my work
is done with my life and I genuinely
enjoy it and it's like would I want to
leave leave work early on a Friday
probably not because it's actually kind
of fun and I
but but that post got loads of likes and
it's as I I I've been trying to figure
out like what is the culture going on
there where
it's like almost almost us against them
almost a sense of like I am you know I'm
a poor employee and my manager is the
one who's forcing me to work really hard
and therefore I'm gonna I'm gonna carve
out this like self-care time for myself
by closing my laptop an hour early any
right any idea on there yeah well so
here's my one Theory but we'll see if
this one sticks I wrote about this one
last fall
um I was like okay here's one thing that
might be going on with with this
particular type of backlash which is in
most if you look in most economic
sectors uh a lot of thought goes into
how the work is actually organized and
assigned and so productivity is
typically a systems issue how do we run
this Factory in a productive way if if
you're on the Ford assembly line it's
not just like you know hey
um do what you can to get these cars out
of here fast like it's a systems issue
right that you think through with
knowledge work unique among all major
economic sectors before that the the
task of productivity was put onto the
individuals made personal it was like
okay it's up to you to figure out how to
organize stuff and get things done so
like I don't know like you should watch
you should read getting things done or
whatever like that's kind of up to you
it's none of our business and there's a
whole reason why that was that has to do
with Peter Drucker and the autonomy
culture surrounding knowledge work
there's various reasons but that's the
case
the issue is when productivity and here
I mean like how you actually like
organize and schedule and execute and
assign tasks is left to the individuals
just to kind of figure out that builds
resentments that's where you get this
interesting resentment because now you
as the individual are are you have to
start making these choices between I
could work more hours tonight
um but now like my personal life is
affecting and now my personal life is
pitted against my professional life and
that's really different than when
productivity is systemic so when the
system so here's how our company assigns
work and how much work we think you
should have in your plate and and you
know how we collaborate or whatever now
you have a clear thing that you can if
it's demanding too much you can push
back against it you can say here's our
system and we think it should be two
projects at a time not three we think it
shouldn't be like you you have a thing
that you can argue about and debate and
have a saying it's such an interesting
trick and this wasn't done on purpose I
think this was accidental but it's such
an interesting devious trick though and
that becomes completely personal now you
have to to wage the battle against
yourself well maybe I could work
Saturday maybe I could work a little bit
more because like I I need to get these
things done and so I think the the
inefficiency and the the personal
internal battles created by in a
corporate setting or organizational
setting just letting everyone figure out
their own personal productivity it just
doesn't work and it's making people
resentful and this is why like a lot of
my Solutions are if you work for a team
or if there's an organization or a
company you can't just say it's none of
our business how you organize your task
you got to be like no no how do we
figure out like where work comes from
where are all the projects we're waiting
on how many are you working on right now
that looks like a full plate like you
shouldn't have to pull on more when do
we talk do we just send emails all day
or do we have uh do we do DACA clearing
meetings and office hours and like just
all of this we need when productivity is
a thing that the system supports you can
see and debate and modify and improve
and have you know it's much better and
when you put it on the people's plates
it's we can't handle it well and we have
to and so I kind of get why people are
getting resentful I also get I agree
with you too that it it also doesn't
seem to make sense from The Outsider
sounds like I'm closing my laptop at
four you're like well I thought the
agreement was you're gonna work you know
eight hours a day or something or I this
happened a lot with the remote work
things I think remote work by the way
these fights about remote work
remote work has just become a proxy for
these frustrations with how knowledge
work comes out so like all of this
frustration and anger and issues of like
its emails all day long and I have way
too much work on my plate and it's all
up to me to figure it out and I'm kind
of tired of this it's all getting
channeled now into like I should be able
to work from home because it's like the
only thing people know to spec it's like
a specific tangible thing you can you
can fight for it's like spoiler alert I
mean you remember 2020 and early 2021
you're still not going to like your work
even if you're at home and your kids are
running around you know it's like not
that much better but this is one of my
working theories is making productivity
personal we take it for granted but it's
a really weird step we took when the
knowledge sector emerged it's kind of a
weird way of doing it hmm nice I look
forward to reading more about this um
what is slow productivity
probably so yeah so if we don't have
here's the issue with knowledge work in
general
the issue we've been grappling with in
the last 20 minutes like what does
productivity even mean right and and so
then it just becomes this weird
catch-all or Boogeyman so I have this
thought of like why don't we actually
positively come out and come up with a
definition that we'd like a definition
that's human a definition that that
melds well with our human instincts and
the way our brain is actually wired
that's centered around producing
meaningful and valuable things but in a
way that's very sustainable in a way
that's very satisfying so so instead of
just pushing Back Against The Boogeyman
productivity like let's put in place an
alternative and the alternative I've
been working on is called slow
productivity and like the slow food
movement or these other movements I've
I've gone back and pulled from these
sort of existing cultures of knowledge
workers that have been around for
centuries in some cases Millennia that
had the privilege and space to kind of
figure out what's the best way to work
with your mind you know what works what
doesn't and figuring out can we have a
widely applicable definition of
productivity that comes out of it and so
slow productivity has three principles
to it do fewer things
working at a natural pace obsessing over
quality
those three things approaching knowledge
work with those three principles
realigns the efforts with uh our
Humanity the way we're wired I can give
you a neuroscience argument for it I can
give you a psychological argument for it
I can give you a philosophical argument
for those three things all on all three
of those levels
orienting knowledge work around that is
Meaningful satisfying you can produce
things a great value it can be very
productive for companies that can be
very satisfying for individuals so I'm
sorry putting together my pitch of what
what Target a productivity should people
who make a living using their brains
what it what should they be going for
Beyond just you know
get after it have your to-do's organized
I don't know what's what's the
philosophical argument
well there's uh like we go back to
Aristotle if we need to right there's
this the what what is the the teleology
of of human existence well what's the
one thing we have that other creature
stone is we have these brains that can
sit and think and create things
um and there's there's a there's a
there's an argument towards the the the
production of things of value and
meaning and sort of giving things the
time they require craftsmanship that
there's there's a real philosophical
Foundation to the human value that's
extracted from actually like doing
things of of value of impact with your
mind and a lot of that gets sapped away
when you're just answering emails all
day uh or just hustling to get after it
you could go all the way back to neuro I
mean this is the the thing I'm working
on now is I I've gone back heavily to do
a deep into the mainly social
anthropological research to do a deep
history of work
for 300 000 years what was work for
humans because that's a long enough time
span that our brain
evolved right the the match this
definition of work and you know surprise
surprise when you go back and look
through this deep literature you see
not doing too many things sees a
variation in Pace and intensity a lot of
your time being the application of hard
one skills like that's exactly what
comes up that's what we did for 300 000
years so there's also this almost like
psychology anthropological even
neuroscientific argument for not being
overloaded varying your intensity in
various ways and spending more of your
time like applying hard-won skills like
what we expect work to be
do you have you stumbled across any kind
of
um Dunbar number for number of active
projects that one should have at a given
time like when you say fewer things I
mean how few are we talking
well yeah I mean I so there's two
different time scales I mean at the
scale of like what you're working on
right now it's one right so like in the
what what we cannot do what our brain
cannot do is concurrently during like
the afternoon go back and forth between
three different things
it just the way our planning motivation
Loop works like we have one thing in our
working memory we build this internal
model that pulls episodic memories out
of the hippocampus we use that to try to
predict what we should do next that
system cannot handle more than one thing
so we cannot be thinking about making
decisions on or making progress on more
than one thing at a time and I don't
mean like literally at the time like
over a couple hours even like work on
one thing till you're done move on to
the other thing our brain cannot go back
and forth It's why email like going back
and forth between your email just
crushes us psychologically uh you know a
recent podcast episode I talked about
task freeze where you see like 15 things
you need to do and you just stop it's
because you literally the planning
motivational Center of your brain can't
make plans for 15 things at the same
time it neurologically can't do that so
your motivation system just freezes up
right so at a time one thing in terms of
like ongoing projects I'm a big believer
in like pull-based methodology or
there's like two or three things your
two or three things you're working on
when something finishes you can pull
something else in
you know and I actually think this is
how companies should organize work
software developers already do this but
I think we should do this more broadly
in knowledge work where yeah there's a
lot of work the company needs to do
don't just distribute that to everyone's
plate and everyone has 20 things that
they have to kind of figure out what to
do with they should just be working on a
couple things and they can pull in new
things once they're once it's ready and
the problem why you need well I think
this is important and why I think it's
killer to have a lot of things on your
plate even if you're not working on them
at the exact same time is that there's
something called an overhead tax that
every project that you have committed to
generates it's a overhead of
administrative work that you have to do
even if you're not actively working on
the project it's emails you have to send
meetings planning meetings standing
meetings you have to have and just
cognitive load of knowing it's there so
that builds up so if you have 15
projects on your plate you're paying
overhead tax on 15 projects and that tax
takes up your time and before you know
it most of your time mental energy is
going to the maintenance of the ongoing
project and almost nothing gets done and
then you fall farther behind and then
the the more projects build up and the
tax gets worse I call it the overhead
spiral it's a terrible state to be in so
there's a real cost to having too many
things on your plate even if you're very
careful about this morning I'm just
working on this and then in the
afternoon I'm just working on that and
on Tuesdays I work on this once you get
past a certain level it's a problem and
I think again it's something companies
get wrong they just say let's distribute
the task informally to everyone we'll
have everything live on people's
individual plates and they can just
figure out what to work on and whatnot
and the overhead text kills them like a
much better system is this all sits in a
holding tank
and when I'm ready for the next thing I
pull it in but until it leaves that
holding tank I'm paying no overhead tax
on it it's not actually it's not
actually my view so I honestly think
like three active projects at a time is
best and obviously when you're working
on something you're only working on that
one thing
yeah this is actually something like as
of last week we have now started doing
in our in our team and it's I'm so
surprised it's taken so long to get to
this because we were in that model of oh
there's all these things we could do
let's just like distribute them but now
we're like oh actually let's do the
thing that software people do and
actually make a I mean we have like a
bucket list of we would love to to have
have my website contain book summaries
of every book I've ever read we'd love
to make think about it patreon we'd love
to think about making our own keyboard
we'd love to think about making our own
bad we'd love to think about this
enormous list of things but not right
now like for the next six weeks we're
just focusing on these things good and
then six weeks later we can reassess the
bucket list and see okay whether we
actually want to put things onto it and
that model has uh basically is like
within half an hour freed up a lot of
cognitive overload from people being
like Oh actually this is not a priority
right now so therefore I'm not going to
think about it until our next six week
Sprint planning or whatever that looks
like yep yep that's 100 right by the way
that's what everyone should be doing I I
have a chapter about this in the new
book I I wrote a couple weeks ago
everyone should be doing that but mainly
only software people do and it's such a
such a it's such a
such an unnecessary unforced source of
stress and overhead I mean just like
this is what I think happened by the way
with the zoom apocalypse so I don't know
if you heard this from your listeners I
definitely was getting this feedback
that during 2021 when everyone we were
everyone's remote knowledge workers were
remote people got to these sort of
absurd states where like all they were
doing was Zoom eight hours a day they're
like wait there's no work left like it
became absurd it was like a Kafka play
or something like this like some sort of
like meta commentary on on the absurdity
of of work and bureaucracy or something
like that but what this was I think was
like a really clear example of the
overhead tax
inspiring out of control because when
people went remote it increased the
amount of task on their plate by like 20
all of a sudden because you had to
figure out how to run whatever you do
remote so it generated new work right to
figure out how do we make the transition
and switching over to uh video
is there's efficiencies that that's lost
so there's a lot of efficiencies in
person where where I can grab you at the
end of a meeting be like wait hold on
like what are we doing about this client
coming tomorrow we go back and forth for
three minutes and figure it out when I
can't do that anymore we're left saying
like we should have a zoom meeting yeah
to talk about the client but what's the
smallest interval on your calendar 30
minutes and so now five minutes becomes
30 minutes so I think the the zoom
apocalypse that happened in like the
summer of 2020 was making the phenomenon
of overhead tax unavoidably visible like
it's like look we we up these things by
about 20 and soon all time went away for
working all time went away for working
and it showed how how perilous like how
how much we we push that tax up almost
to the Limit like before the pandemic we
must have already been spending so much
of our time just talking about work
because when it got 20 worse we couldn't
ignore it anymore because people were
writing me and saying I don't know when
to go to the bathroom because it's back
to back to back to back to back for
seven hours of you know it got so absurd
that people were like okay obviously
this this can't be right but we were
like right below that for years and
years so I think it's a huge phenomenon
and we really should spend more time
thinking about it yeah yeah this is
something that we're trying to figure
out right now in terms of
um you know we're moving into this new
like sort of office type thing and I'm
trying to figure out what's a good
balance between oh having on Team B
somewhat remote and also somewhat in
person where in person
just those conversations happen the
three minute conversation that I just
had about pricing for one of our courses
which would have happened maybe never or
in like a sort of one hour long course
debrief and stuff and actually just it
just took a few like bouncing a couple
of ideas as I was refilling my water
bottle
um to actually come up with a pretty
solid idea and we just don't get that in
Zoom meetings because like who's gonna
bother arranging Zoom meeting and then
when some people are remote and some
people are not it's like you're having a
conversation about a thing but then it's
just like a lot of effort to update the
person who is also involved in that
project because you you're never going
to be like hey let's hop on a zoom
meeting just so I can update you about
this 30 second conversation I had but
then that person is out of the loop and
it just ends up creating this this mess
um have you in your thinking about this
figured out a magic solution or is it
still a like uh We've gotta kind of work
through this and figure it out
well like my take on remotes I did a
bunch of pieces on this too like this
was like a big issue especially during
the pandemic is
you have to for remote to succeed it has
to be accompanied by really rethinking
and getting much more smart and
structured about how just work happens
in your organization in general right so
like think about for example what
economic sector in knowledge work
already had successful widespread remote
work before the pandemic hit it was
software
there's lots of software development
firms that are remote
um how are they able to pull it off well
think as we've just been talking about
software development is highly
structured like we we have we're using
an agile methodology we have this pull
methodology with these with these highly
structured collaborative status meetings
we know the point of the status meetings
we then do the Sprints everything was
already really well structured so we
they understood okay if we're going to
move you out of this location we know
exactly how to integrate you into the
workflow when you don't have that so
most offices just run off what I call
the hyperactive hive mind like we just
rock and roll back and forth grab people
messages email slack uh when you go
remote it just amplifies the issues
which is why I keep saying like that the
making the debate that's happening now
just about can I be remote or not like
do you have to be in the office or not
it's missing like you have to actually
structure your work and then if you
understand exactly how things are
assigned when things are discussed then
it's much easier to figure out who can
be remote and who can't and and so I
mean I see a future in which
hybrid work is going to succeed when
things are much more clear and segmented
like you're not here
but because of that we don't think of
you as the same that we think of the
like this core planning team that is
here like probably what you're working
on for us is it's much more clarifying
yeah it's much more like you're taking
this uh you're working on it and you're
coming back and producing giving us what
you've produced it's it's uh you know
it's it's much more segmented in that
way but then this other type of group we
have here we're all here we're all in
London because there's like a lot of
planning and decisions that have to
happen and there's huge efficiencies uh
in the in-person interaction right
there's all these efficiencies in it you
know I wrote this thing once about
um World War II talk about remote work
there's a reason why if you go back and
look in World War II Churchill and
Roosevelt would go through literal risk
to life and limb to travel and meet each
other
uh they had telegraphs they had
telephones but there's just there's
something in the in-person interaction
that was that was so important that you
know they would actually uh take ships
and fly from Greenland or whatever like
do really dangerous things right to do
this and George Marshall our chief of
staff would go over to Europe and you
know whatever right so there's something
to it so I think we're going to see much
more segmented clearly defined roles
more clearly to find systems for how
work is assigned and executed and
reported back once you have that then
you can figure out
how does this work and so it might be
some people are in person some people
are remote it might be I wrote about
this this uh a particular proposal
that's out there Chris heard the
entrepreneur Chris heard had this
proposal where it's everyone's remote
but then gathers on these sort of
semi-regular basis not at a set office
it could be all the way all around the
country you gather every month or two
and it's like a hyper in-person session
where like all these decisions are made
and figured out and when you get all
those advantages of being in person and
team building and then everyone
disperses and executes and comes back so
I think there's a lot of options but the
option it doesn't work is we were kind
of doing this and now we're still doing
this but like if you want to be on Zoom
you can it does not when you just
informally insert some remoteness into
your work that's not the right way to do
that which is why I think most companies
are going to be coming back to in person
before we see further Innovation most
companies in the pandemic just said like
look we got to go remote because of like
virus stuff and made no other
substantive changes to how work executes
and so the friction of that inefficiency
I think is collapsing most companies
back to in person
they're going to have to then re-go back
out into Innovative forms but only once
they actually rethink like how work
actually happens yeah no this is all the
stuff that we're in the process of
attempting to figure out having doubled
with various degrees of remote and
hybrid and in person as I'm sure is
everyone who's listening to this and who
has a job
um final thing I'd like to I'd love to
talk to you about and um it would be it
would be great to do a part two of this
if you're ever in London in the near
future
um that would be sick to meet up in
person but I guess one of the things I
love about your work is that you pull in
from all sorts of different sources
um and like even in this conversation
you know talking about like Aristotle or
talking about World War II and Churchill
and martial it's not like what does your
reading process look like are you kind
of Ryan holiday with a little note cards
like what's your what's your method for
I guess ingesting information from stuff
and then doing stuff with said
information
well so so yeah I do uh I call the
Corner marking method so it's much lower
friction than Ryan's more zettel cast in
style like capturing ideas on cards that
you then uh that you then file
um so what I do is if I'm reading a
non-fiction source that I think I will
need for a book or article if there's
something on a page that seems relevant
you put a line across the corner
at the upper so you can find that real
quickly see there's like a little hash
mark up in the corner and then I'll uh
bracket out the relevant sentences and
that's it right so Mark the corner
bracket out the things you think are
relevant what I found is that maybe you
lose a little bit information but I you
can go back and take a book and I was
just doing this today 500 page book and
in four minutes just flip through and
find every page that is corner marked
read those bracketed uh sentences and in
about five minutes you can basically
load back up like oh yeah I remember
what was interesting in this book I
remember what this book was about I did
that the other day for a book I read
probably in 2009
a present shark by by Douglas ruskoff
there's something I wanted from it and I
went through and went through my
markings five minutes
that whole book is swapped back in like
the stuff that the stuff that really
matters so I love that method because
it's incredibly low friction it barely
slows down your writing and there's
almost I mean you're reading there's no
overhead like you don't have to go and
then like laboriously uh like I think
the subtle cast and folks will spend a
lot of time
processing their thoughts from the books
afterwards but I go through a lot of
books and and I just I'm not going to do
that and I don't want that overhead to
stop me from actually reading so that's
why it's a pencil uh
that's it can I play
um Cal thank you so much this has been
wonderful um any final parting bits of
advice uh having like so so you know
what stage of the process I'm at just
somewhat handed in the first draft but
now we're in for probably six months
worth of or maybe more of just this
editing back and forth to try and make
this absolute third of 80 000 words that
I currently have into something of
vaguely presentable any any tips from a
Season Pro
well I mean first I'll say editing is
always more fun than writing for the
first time so that's good news because
you have the foundation you're moving
things around you're cutting things down
and also it just the stuff you come away
with from the sessions is better because
you're like hey made this thing better
um cutting is usually the right answer
that's like the other when I'm when I'm
like wrangling with something I'm I'm
I cut and then I feel better like oh
it's it's a it's simpler like let's get
rid of that story you know kill kill
your your anecdotal babies like let's
just cut that one of that one and just
like form it around this one get right
to the point you know hit it hit it and
get out so you know editing is funner
than writing so that's good and two
simplifying is always the right move at
least in my case the as I simplify it
things get tighter yeah I get happy with
the writing
so that's pretty excited you're at 80
000 words what's your target you think
you're gonna do it's like 675 ish I I
feel like shorter is probably better
um but at the same time I still have
this like oh but what if there's not
enough material will people feel
shortchanged if the book's not big
enough then I think no obviously not
people prefer a shorter book anyway so
why don't I just like
cut out the fluff and yeah
how how long was digital minimalism
because that was quite small in
paperback oh minimalism it was probably
here I have it here somewhere it's 780
70 or 80. wow okay what about deep work
because that was pretty big but I I
guess I'm just sort of thinking in terms
of how thick the paperbacks are
yeah so you're in UK I think yeah so
it's complicated because well It's
tricky because I think the the trim size
for digital mineralism in the UK was
bigger so the pages are bigger right and
deep work has a smaller trim size yeah
there's a lot I don't know it I I always
misdudge that but if I'm usually like 70
to 90 000 words right yeah it's working
for like my final thing I'll say by
about about uh book writing is um
I always think about the book I'm when
I'm trying to finish up I'm like well my
goal here is just to make this
reasonable the next one will be great
and then like so in other words like and
then that that helps me not get too
worried about like is this right are
people going to like it and then as soon
as I finish a book I'll start thinking
about the next one you know once it's
out of your hands you know you move on
to the next things incredible well thank
you so much this has been wonderful uh
when can people learn more about you if
they want to uh check out more of your
stuff
uh so I have a podcast deep questions
which you can you can listen to or Watch
the episodes on YouTube and then my
newsletter every week I write an essay
on the stuff you can sign up at
calnewport.com ready Cal thank you so
much for taking the time thanks for
having me all right so that's it for
this week's episode of Deep dive thank
you so much for watching or listening
all the links and resources that we
mentioned in the podcast are going to be
linked down in the video description or
in the show notes depending on where
you're watching or listening to this if
you're listening to this on a podcast
platform then do please leave us a
review on the iTunes Store it really
helps other people discover the podcast
or if you're watching this in full HD or
4k on YouTube then you can leave a
comment down below and ask any questions
or any insights or any thoughts about
the episode that would be awesome and if
you enjoyed this episode you might like
to check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye